lady antebellum have decided to change
their name after the acknowledged
antebellum had ties to slavery it will
now be known as lady a they've already
made the change on all their social
media running on instagram when we set
out together almost 14 years ago we
named our band after the southern
antebellum style home where we took our
first photos as musicians that reminded
us of all the music born in the south
that influenced us southern rock blues
R&B gospel and of course country but we
are regretful and embarrassed to say
that we did not take into account the
associations that weighed down this word
referring to the period of history
before the civil war which includes
slavery we are deeply sorry for the hurt
this has caused and for anyone who has
felt unsafe I'm seeing her unvalued yeah
they continue causing pain was never our
hearts intention but it doesn't change
the fact that indeed it did just that so
today we speak up and make a change we
feel like we have been awakened but this
is just one step there countless more
that need to be taken we want to do
better
our next outward step will be a donation
to the equal justice initiative through
lady aid mm-hmm
and it should be added though that the
change to lady a though probably
well-intentioned
is gonna be complicated now too because
there is an artist named Lady a a blues
singer from Seattle she's 61 year old
black woman who's been using the name
Lady a for over 20 years and so now she
has spoken out also to say well you know
I have to deal with Lady Antebellum you
know or then being called Lady a now do
I get to keep my name I'm she has a lot
more to say that and then I can
paraphrase here but that's another your
wonder this yeah legal battle there
that's gonna happen well I mean you know
it would not have taken a extensive
amount of research and that one figure
out the history of the word Antebellum
before you call yourself that
you know 15 years ago when you started
the band that's fine I understand that
like you made a mistake and you want
apologize for it and I appreciate that
apology
the idea of then going on to use a name
that is being used by a black artist now
that seems like that seems unforgivable
to me it's not
it's it would not have taken a lot of
research to just discover that I'm to
discover that someone is already using
that name a black woman no less and
maybe you should find a new one no now
having said that like they picked the
name lady a because their fans call them
lady a right all the time but it's just
this is really telling of the amount of
care that went into this rich I think
like while they were trying to get you
know as quickly as possible on the
moment and they ended up kind of like
missing out on this you know like that's
that's a big misstep yeah
they says sorry this has gone too far I
thought this country and she's talking
about all the things that are getting
canceled right now or you know people
are calling it which no I don't think
this is too far it's funny I did see it
tweets about this maybe three days ago
wasn't it wasn't a huge name that
tweeted it but someone brought up yeah
the lady is developing which has always
been a thing that's been mocked a bit of
a little bit never really brought to the
forefront I will say that because like
when I saw that tweet I was like oh I
wonder if this is gonna really gain
steam and it hadn't yet so the one thing
I will give the lady antebellum that
they got out in front of this because I
think they weren't gonna be calling
because most the time it's yeah people
would called out it's you know this huge
like steamroll of things and then they
you know someone makes it change but
yeah I do appreciate that at least Lady
Antebellum God headed this a little bit
and did it themselves cuz this it wasn't
like they just did this yesterday like
when they announced that yesterday
all of a sudden yeah like all their
branding change like it wasn't like oh
we're gonna do this like obviously this
is gonna work for a few days and then
they did all at once made the change but
yeah now there's a more other element
the fact that yeah this artist is
speaking out that they've taken her name
so yeah the artist just spoke out you
know a few hours ago so yeah I think
there's going to be legal issues or
something that that happens yeah yeah
that's a great optics either technically
she should be able to have claim to the
name if there's ever some sort of legal
trouble going in there but I you know
what are some good names that lady a can
call themselves now that Lady Antebellum
can call themselves now what's another
something else to think of because they
can't go by Lady a now I think you gotta
give this lady back her name lady
something else gonna grind lady maybe
something else yeah that's good yeah
lisa says i don't see the difference in
the name change lady aid like the a
still means Antebellum no difference
whether the fans choose it or not been
stuffing the optics but i don't know
what maybe they can do something with
their three names like yeah they're good
have to make a whole new name i think
fans want all of them like they're crazy
popular so i don't think it's going to
be a big deal after that amendment
change interesting oh no go ahead no go
ahead
I was saying it was interesting to have
this fall this week because like earlier
this week the Grand Ole Opry issued this
statement be like yeah we've had racism
and and and we also don't like it or
something to that effect I'm watering
down this statement a little bit because
it was a really long history of racism
in country music and and and I say this
because like just so last week I wrote
it down about how country music has
always been black music the black roots
of co2 music and and the black artists
who have kind of always been pushing the
genre genre forward and and like the
story of these artists tends to be that
country doesn't recognize them as
foundational they just kind of recognize
it was like here's like this one-off
moment here's this one-off moment of
another person of color another black
person who is doing country music and
then it's kind of forget about it then I
said that it happens and so country has
a lot of reckoning to do I like a lady a
lady a I'm totally changed your name are
doing this now I like with the Opera is
doing this now but boy like there's a
lot there's a lot to root out there yeah
just like I think your audio kind of
right when he said Rolling Stone yes so
if people want to check out your your
article your audio just kind of for half
a second there Nelson's yeah just just
lady alkyl says respect to them for
doing it takes a big risk for Asians
today to make a major change so yeah
we'll see what happens this is a
developing story we'll call it one of
those